let me I'll whiz through them first of
all because um and that point actually
that Beth was making uh about household
disposable incomes and put that in so it
doesn't get in the way that's also an
interesting one that we we need to look
at in a moment um but first of all you
know the big numbers uh because you know
really this is a different picture for
the UK economy than it was uh only a few
months ago let's start with gross
domestic product this is basically how
fast the economy is going we need to do
this stuff we need to look at how the
economy is doing because it's the first
time we've had at an obr forecast
remember this has been delayed delay
delayed it's the first time we've had an
official forecast from the government
which feeds into everything else uh
since March now last time around this
was what was expected okay in the coming
years so 22 23 and so on let's bring in
these latest figures we've just got from
the government so actually slightly
stronger growth in the year we're in at
the moment but look that's the recession
okay and the obr thinks we are in
recession right now down by 1.4 percent
uh next year compared with an increase
of 1.8 which was previous expectation
but another thing that's worth just
drawing your attention to I mean that's
the big story first of all but the thing
that worth worth noting is look these
are quite strong numbers in the future
years you know quasi-quartang was
talking about wanting to get up to 2.5
percent GDP in the future well we're
kind of at that level so that's growth
recession but actually straight stronger
than expected uh off in the future
inflation I said earlier didn't I that
these number Bars were going to go up
didn't take a genius to work that out I
should say but look there they are 9.1
inflation uh this year at 7.4 next year
so a lot higher than previously expected
but look at this as well look you've got
negative inflation deflation in 2025 so
a big question as to whether uh the
recessionary forces are going to force
that through into the system so that's
interesting too and then finally when it
comes to these numbers The Big Numbers
let's look at borrowing so you've got
public accessor net borrowing this is
the total amount the government is
borrowing in these years going out into
the future the higher the bars are the
more they are borrowing uh last time
around blue bars this time around red
bars have a look I'm going to bring them
on and there you can see an enormous
shift much more borrowing this year next
year and also also on into the future
and this is the interesting thing talk
about austerity talk about getting that
down but actually in practice much
higher borrowing figures off into the
future than were previously forecast uh
back in March so that is a big change uh
from what we had uh only a few months
ago and it's worth actually finally okay
one thing quickly I'm going to try and
fit this in because we're talking about
Market reaction weren't we this is the
government bond yield over the course of
the last few hours look it jumped a bit
during the statement okay people got a
little bit nervous around them but look
it's come down quite a lot the
government will be quite pleased by that
we're not seeing that kind of reaction
the scary reaction we saw after the mini
budget so far at least but let's see
what happens uh over the course of the
next few hours because you know the
day's stood young and I'm sure you're
going to be keeping track of that for us
lots of analysis still to come